he runs vaynermedia one of the world's
hottest digital agencies his
single-handedly created a movement to
put the marketing world on snapchat if
you want to learn how to do well on
snapchat you want to learn from Gary
Vaynerchuk mentor me Gary
hey guys you're about to watch a clip
that I did in 2013 where I kind of
started telling the world of my intent
or belief in a snapchat you know I also
wrote this article back in 14 about you
know you disrespecting the ghosts when I
think it's got huge upside I think
2016-2017 are gonna be the years were in
the marketing world and the business
world really recognized what's actually
happening in snapchat which is snapchat
right this minute is the closest thing
to Facebook 2007 and eight that I've
seen since then and and I just you know
this is almost like a last ditch effort
video to try to get you into a place of
like this is gonna happen you need to
figure it out there's a lot of nuances
within snapchat you need to get in there
become native because it's going to be a
massively important massively important
platform platform and will be one to one
I think brands and businesses can send a
snap to 10,000 people that are following
them and then when they open it for
those 10 seconds they're actually paying
attention yeah and so what if the snap
said take a picture screenshot of this
and scan at the register for 10% off I
think people will do things like that or
take a snapshot of this and tweeted at
me and I'll give you my ebook for free
now you've got people putting out tweets
to their community with you on it got it
so I think there's a lot of gamification
that can have a snapchat you know why
the snapchat forces you to pay attention
email Facebook Twitter we think we can
get back to it don't we email me I'll
see you again on my screen snapchat you
know that once you look at it it
disappears forever yeah which requires
you to actually pay attention yes and so
what we are all in the business of
attention and everybody worries about
the hot top line how many visitors you
have email followers that doesn't matter
it matters top line matters but
conversion is what matters and snapchat
focus conversion in my opinion right now
snapchat is one of the most successful
marketing tools for me personally with
my brand everybody worries about win
right like everybody cares about
top-line numbers impressions followers
people care about dumb data what
snapchat is doing everybody is very
simple it's not about how many
impressions you get it's how much
attention you get I don't care what
anybody in this room does or watching at
home on livestream the number one thing
we all have to do is tell our story to
somebody along the path of them making a
decision before you tell your story you
have to have somebody's attention and
what snapchat does is it gives you the
attention how do you grow audience on
snapchat yeah so snapchat has no natural
in snapchat app discovery which is thing
with a lot of people's heads cuz they're
like what the hell like where is this
suggested user list where can I search
how do I run ads like I can't grow of
course you can you grow the old way free
internet apps infrastructure you use
other things to grow your business I
built this business using a newspaper
and a radio and other things of that
nature so the answer is absolutely I
think he was going there I mean watch my
behavior it's not super complicated I'm
using my Twitter my email my facebook my
Instagram to drive awareness towards my
channel I'm hitting up I mean I don't
think I remember throwing this many
right hooks outside of a book ask which
is weird because I'm doing that right
now as well
stopping March 8th go get it I've asked
plenty of people when they've sent me
emails like oh you've really helped my
snapchat
these are historically emails that I
would reply to and say thanks have a
great day now I'm saying hey and your
next story shout out my at gary vee
handle i'm going in for the ask how
about the bottom of your email signature
how about your username on instagram go
look at mine you hack to build awareness
for it you think about billboards and
print where there's no click or
permalinks or anything
nature no it's just awareness drives you
don't have to move huh it's got a live
angle damn it I was trying to make you
move know where drew I was very
impressed with unity rock we're a
drinking kind of that was a standoff
that you won which it pisses me off
where you drive awareness to your handle
so yes any means of awareness I mean
sooner I'm gonna put a sign in here that
says follow Gary on a snapchat so yes
that's the answer using other platforms
to drive awareness to get followers from
that platform but scalable ones email
signatures your LinkedIn account look at
my Instagram profile things like that
you know I think one of the biggest
mistakes by so many snapchat and YouTube
influencers right now is they want to
become Hollywood famous because they
grew up where that was the pinnacle and
to me I keep trying to remind them my
early days with Jerome and Rudy and
Britney for a lot and that whole space
with the vine influencers that we're
definitely the spark that you've watched
the Instagram and snapchat thing very
different than generation of YouTube
that I grew up with is guys in 2022 in
2024 the most famous person is not the
person that's on a TV show on MTV it's
the person that dominates this which is
the new television just like being a
cable star wasn't interesting in the
early 80s but then eventually if you're
the number one star on an HBO show which
to remind everybody you guys are too
young for this each P was a chair was a
place to go in 1982 and 1984 1986 you
were a BC list d-list a flesh nobody
wanted to be a Netflix star 48 months
ago nobody now everybody wants to in
Hollywood so first and foremost Aaron I
think that you need to decide what you
want to happen do you want to get your
art into the world is it about money is
it about fame and I think you need to
own your vanity because way too many
people try to bull bit number one number
two you got to go where the attention is
to me enormous emphasis on snapchat and
YouTube and now look one minute
Instagram videos probably opens up a lot
of creativity for a lot of people here
and definitely people that are watching
so that becomes a new thing and look
musically actually it's a question for
me real quick are any of the three of
you playing on musically
yeah downloaded
they're uh he's talked about it a couple
times have you kind of have you had the
time yet to spend to look at what's
going on there little bit yeah and so
this is what's so interesting right a
lot of my youtube celebrity friends when
vine came along with like a and I'm like
and I'm like you you came from YouTube
that's what was just being said five
minutes ago now then a lot of fun
snapchat came I was selling a lot of
Viners I'm like this thing I'm telling
you and everything yeah and then of
course now everybody's there and now
even musically right like snapchat as
it's at its apex but ironically I think
the snapchatters and if I'm giving you
advice right now that go and really go
all in on musically they're gonna win
those junior high people are gonna be
here in 36 months and be like holy [ __ ]
that was a good idea or it could go away
but much like what happened on vine and
this is such a good learning from vine
and we were talking about vine off as
the rock broke the sound and you know
the people that won on vine have been
able to siphon that attention and be
successful in other platforms not
everybody and it exactly not everybody
because some of them wouldn't have held
on vine either because they didn't have
enough talent to be anything more than a
few minutes but some were and that's no
different than being a really good actor
on a hit show on CBS for two seasons and
then coming back two years later on ABC
and siphoning some of that audience and
building on that momentum I think that
people are not practitioners I would
argue that ninety-five percent of people
in marketing ninety-five percent of
people in marketing at digital and
social agencies on the brands and the
business sides actually don't know how
snapchat works actually have never went
through all four screens of snapchat to
the left to the right twice and the
camera itself literally have not done
that literally I would argue that
seventy percent of marketers have never
touched one of the discover tabs on
snapchat because they are just not
practitioners and snapchat has a context
and a cadence and a system that is not
native to a lot of people because it's
left-to-right not up and down like all
the other apps and so there's some
learning like it actually takes four to
five minutes of thought and energy to
really understand how snapchat works if
you've never used it before and that's
about four to five minutes worth of
actual practitioner ship that most
people don't apply they like the
headline read that
the kids send sex pictures to each other
and they like to be old white men even
if they're not old white men right
plenty of 23 year-old hispanica women
acting like old white men cuz they're
not practicing or slang term old white
men - like you suck like you're not
putting in the work you're tired you're
not innovating you stink you stink you
stink and so why do I think people are
scared of snapchat because they stink
because most people suck at marketing
most people just want to do what they've
already known they don't evolve I wake
up every morning of my life trying to
put myself out of business because it's
a lot better to do that than have
somebody else do it for me and that's
how I live and that's how I'm gonna live
until I'm an old white man acting like a
14 year old chick right cuz that's just
the way I'm gonna roll I think a lot of
brands are gonna go for the lowest
common denominator which is they're
gonna run contests or follow us on you
know on snapchat and blah blah blah will
happen and you can win a free trip or
free this or dadada what I think the
right thing to do is make an incredible
story and then download a piece of it
right and then upload it on your other
channels so that when people see it in a
tweet or in a Facebook post or an
Instagram 15 second clip they get so
excited about well what else is there it
compels them to go follow it the content
is always king you know we say the
marketing all the time it's super cliche
the problem is most people don't execute
on it and so instead of doing a cheap
move just to get as many views on your
story as possible by giving stuff away
or incentivizing it I say make great
quality content use your other social
vehicles and other digital and even
traditional vehicles to share that
content and then compel people to come
and watch hey Gary Vaynerchuk jld here
and I have a question for you about
snapchat because of you I've been
snapping my face off and loving every
second of it d-roc at John Lee Dumas and
I would love for you to share with us
how do we grow our snapchat followers
you've answered this question before I
haven't loved any of your answers if you
could go deep let's break it down we're
vaynernation
how do we grow our snapchat
all jld wants to grow his base jld
excited I think I'm actually going on
your podcast today which she'll probably
air as the book comes out myths later in
my day Joe they listen I'm sorry that
I'm not giving you a good answer the
answer is you have to use every other
channel it's using every other channel
and it's hacking you're doing it right
now you threw up your snapcode because
you're hoping a bunch of people in the
vaynernation stop it
take a picture of it and add you as a
friend you're doing exactly the right
thing which is you've got to use other
people's platforms and other you know I
collaborating like literally emailing
everybody that you know or messaging
them on Instagram if they have big
instagrams assuming that that that means
they have some sort of community on
snapchat and saying hey how do I take
over your channel how do I give me a
shout out I mean it's literally
endorsements on other people's snapchat
or you I mean listen man make your
podcast over the next six seven weeks
pounding snapchat interview people about
snapchat interview snapchat executives
make your world about snapchat I've won
because I branded you're looking for a
tactic you're looking for a sales tactic
write a transaction oh go do this by
this search term did the big right like
you're looking for that you're looking
for maybe you should buy the longtail
term on Google as a google adword that
says who should I follow on snapchat and
then maybe you're the first result that
you paid for it it's me follow me
right that will work probably cost a
buck or two per follower and that might
work but I'm doing it in marketing and
branding by being about it about it
right by being about it and by talking
about it and by being out there people
are picking up on that behavior they're
writing about me being in there and yes
I sit at a high level in marketing but
there's a lot of people DJ Khaled wasn't
he was a DJ he went all about it now
people give them exposure right now
because there's no functionality within
snapchat to growth hack or pay for ad
spend or any other functionality to
build your user base you have to win on
marketing not on sales jld there's too
many people in 2016 that have become
internet marketers and it's all about
arbitrage Facebook ads Pinterest ads
Google AdWords affiliate marketing email
marketing landing page optimization it's
all about tactics it's not about
marketing and religion
I've done so well on snapchat is I'm a
marketer right I don't want my brand
marketing not just transactional
couponing and Google AdWords I fill
myself in in marketing coming I built
myself in marketing by building my brand
and that's trickle down it's not just
transactional I sell a lot more books
than a lot of people because it's not
the tactics it's the overall brand it's
really the thesis of jabs are jab right
hook those jabs are branding I'm
bringing value and so there's tactics
like you just did it's jld but there's
also branding and you have a platform
you have a successful podcast make your
content about that and then there's a
lot of tactics like I mentioned earlier
in this rant as I wove some tactics in
there for you but you've got a level up
you're thinking bro I'm not kidding you
know you're gonna rise I'm gonna rise
right back you got to think marketing
versus you know you're more than welcome
to go out and do guest blog posts on a
ton of business sites about why you
think snapchats important and now you
show up in a lot of distributed places
with a call to action to o-p-s by the
way follow me on snapchat so there's a
lot you know you may not like the
answers because you may not want to do
them or you might not like this answer
because marketing is a lot harder than a
growth hack or an execution it doesn't
take away from the fact that it's the
answer the reason so many people are
asking me how to build a base is because
it's not easy because it's branding and
marketing not sales and transactional
I'm excited right now because I was
actually a very important answer to a
lot of questions that have going on for
a long time too many people here are
playing checkers when the game is really
chess branding and marketing is
different than transactional affiliate
it's math versus branding it's quant
purses quoi snapchat isn't branding in
qua world and that's just too hard for
most of you Gary how on earth do you
measure your progress on snapchat Abdul
that's very easy it's called how many
views are you getting on your stories a
week ago I was getting three thousand
views now I'm getting 20,000 views on
making progress
okay making progress Abdul we're making
progress Abdul I think you brought more
people on the snapchat then you are the
snapchat marketing maven I always had a
challenge with with stuff that just
disappears I like creating stuff that
lives forever like you mention at the
top of the show that you know 10 years
people will still come back and watch
this video I hate the idea of creating
something and then poof it's gone like
the street artist writing something down
and then the rain washes it away am i
seeing it wrong or it's just ok so
what's what's I guess I think it's there
but I want like the left lasting stuff
well good do both you can download the
stories and upload them like you can do
a ton of things and sure yeah I mean
every conversation you've ever had in
life disappears sure mode most
television pre DVR all television pre
DVR days it's like yeah I mean I think
got and by the way not everything has to
do the same thing and most of all the
value of that attention is extreme you
know like people are just gonna be there
it's just gonna happen you know I'm a
very big believer of like look whether I
like it or not it's gonna be and so you
know I forgot you that is building his
brand as a curator of content and I and
excuse me if I'm wrong with that that's
just kind of how I see it from afar so
far like I don't see how I don't see how
how you can't afford in my opinion to
punt snapchat it's gonna be too big so
so to me it starts with that religion
right like if you fully believe that
great you know if you fully believe that
then that alone in itself but yeah I
mean like I mean I think it's kind of
cool oh sorry man I don't know what's
going on hello good night you okay cool
you know I I think that um I think that
there's gonna be different genres of
ways to communicate and and if snapchat
doesn't work for you that's fine but I'm
telling you like a homie like just don't
disrespect it cuz it's gonna be a beast
okay I'm yeah I get it I'm also not huge
on Instagram or doing a ton on Twitter
or Facebook a lot I just hate the
business of things disappearing I want
the stuff I make to last forever
well Instagram you you making one minute
versions for Instagram and being smart
about hashtags would blow up your okay
good advice write it down and you know
the good thing about advice is like look
you don't have to you've got like I
always think that people need like
people give me advice all the time I
completely disregard it like you do you
but like that's one man's point of view
you know thank you guys so much for
watching
I made them mentor me series because I
wanted you to be able to hang out with
people who've done a lot more and
hopefully by hanging around those people
just a little bit more some extra there
magic pixie dust rubs off on you and
starts to change the way you think you
act you behave so hopefully you enjoyed
this video I'd love to know what you
think of it if you want to leave it in
the comments below and if you have a
snapchat ID that you'd like to promote
or question about snapchat or want to
tell people how you're using chap chat
your experiences leave it in the
comments below and I will join a
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon